late January
1993 a few excruciating days since the
Australian glossy magazine new idea
published the full transcription of
Prince Charles and mistress Camilla's
embarrassing telephone conversation
she was tabloid toast
she was the Wicked Witch of the East you
know the Press worldwide continues to
publish the tawdry details
press the tit
darling
the British public is in total shock the
palace blindsided is yet to comment and
Prince Charles is nowhere to be seen
where's Camilla the woman who had been
enjoying an illicit and suddenly
headline-making affair with the Future
King published
published a family she's in the kitchen
of a wheelchair home sat at the table
smoking cigarettes staring out of the
window and struggling to make sense of
the explosive events of the last few
days
at the end of the driveway of the home
she still shares with her husband Andrew
are hordes of frenzied reporters and
photographers with long lenses desperate
for a word or a glimpse of Mrs Parker
Bowles the Mistress of the Prince of
Wales
already labeled the most hated woman in
Britain Camilla bore the heavy burden
alone according to her friend Kathy Lett
just suddenly find yourself as Public
Enemy Number One and to be such a hate
figure and be kind of on the dartboard
of the national consciousness
must have been horrific The Witch Hunt
you know they practically had her on a
broomstick at the time
Charles is not only a husband to Diana
but also the father of two young Sons
their boys William then 11 and Harry
nine Camilla 2 has a family older but
just as vulnerable to the public gays
Tom now studying at Oxford University
and Laura still at school how will this
impact on them
for private conversations to be made
public was just the most horrendous
thing Christina kiriakum Charles's
former Communications secretary says the
couple had public pressures to face even
before this headline Grabber the
sanctity of marriage is something that
the head of the church has to take
incredibly seriously surely it's now
game over for Charles and Camilla
Charles II acknowledged the public wrath
Camilla to face a more private but
equally judgmental husband
not quite so fast says Phil Craig
co-author of the best-selling book Diana
story of a princess the clue he says is
with the tape
you here is a couple who are clearly
very much in love and need each other
and everybody focuses on the sexual and
the salacious part of the tape
but what's really interesting about it
is the preamble
he is trailing a new speech and she is
giving him supportive comments and
telling him how clever he is and how
grateful people should be to him for
what he does
and it wasn't like that Diana would have
told him what she thought and it might
not have been very complementary he
likes to do things a certain way he
likes to be treated a certain way
Camilla was more than happy to be that
supportive partner as you can hear in
the tape and Camilla clearly is the sort
of partner that he needs
despite all that she stands to lose
Camilla motivated by loyalty possibly
and love most probably chooses to do and
say nothing
and in doing so she unwittingly sets
herself up as the perfect foil to one
person in the British royal family who
has been empowered by the whole of this
scandal
Diana Princess of Wales this is episode
2 of Sky News is Queen Camilla For the
Love of Charles
[Music]
the royal family is now engulfed by the
crisis Diana has become the force to be
reckoned with
you have to remember
to remember just how bad things looked
after the publication of the Camilla
gate tape for Charles and for Camilla it
was a shocking moment and a moment of
total Vindication for Diana
what she chooses to do next will shape
not only her future but that of the
whole of the House of Windsor The Better
or For Worse the lives of Camilla and
Diana and their fortunes are now
inextricably linked as Phil Craig
remembers
she'd written in her book the one that
she more or less dictated to Andrew
Morton and she revealed the relationship
Charlton his supporters had denied it as
said that Camilla is a friend
and Diana is paranoid that was the line
that was being spread and so suddenly
here's his tape and it's obvious that
not only are Charles and Camilla a lot
more close than friends and this was
really really bad for Charles and you
know Diana became a kind of global icon
of female victimhood at this point quite
rightly every woman that had ever been
cheated on and then lied about and
gaslit as we now say sympathize with
Diner very much and I think many of them
still do weeks turn into months Camilla
continues to lay low she struggles to
eat and the pounds fall away she can be
increasingly found with her mother whose
health is in Decline it must have been
very hard to go in public
a few months after those tapes came out
certainly there was a suggestion that
people would start throwing tampons at
Camilla and things like that Diana's own
affair with the Cavalry Officer James
Hewitt had ended only months earlier
after several years but that Revelation
was nothing compared to the scandal of
Charles and Camilla for the vast
majority of the British public as well
as Sky News Royal correspondent Simon
McCoy there was only one side you could
possibly take most people were thinking
about Diana and the effect this was all
going to have on her
and people were very upset phoning
program after phoning program had people
saying poor Diana this poor Diana that
and of course that's true because
everybody was pointed to Camilla as that
evil woman and the Rottweiler as Diana
herself had called it but hindsight I
think can be a little Kinder on those
directly involved and and no one comes
out of it incredibly well in that you
know Charles was committing adultery
Diana was too Camilla was but Camilla's
husband was as well we're talking about
a complicated time
and it was about to become even more
complicated the royal family has split
into two groups Camp Charles and Camilla
and Camp Diana the public with the
guidance of an Ever hungry media would
fall in line with one camp or the other
but not both Phil Craig again Dinah was
probably a bit more of a kind of Sloan
Ranger than Camilla feeling more the
country house set I mean the difference
really I suppose is that Diana had a
kind of love for the cameras and a way
of attracting the Limelight and enjoyed
that and then tried later to turn that
to
in an unusual directions for a royal at
the time the causes that she embraced um
it's hard to see Camilla being that sort
of person Diana's friends were younger
they put they were young officers in the
military they were stock Brokers and
they run tour around London in in in
golf gtis and they drank too much and
they were all the loud and they liked
going skiing
and that was her world Camilla moved in
a world of slightly older more worldly
wise people into these Country House
parties where they would ride and hunt
and jump in our bed with each other
through the Tabloid coverage Diner
becomes even more relatable even more
popular in the eyes of her already
adoring public at the same time Camilla
and Charles's popularity sinks ever
deeper something will have to be done
the war of the Wales is is about to be
born
18 months since the world learned about
Charles and Camilla's Affair in all of
that time neither have made any comment
nor given any explanation about the true
nature of their relationship The
Narrative has instead been left to Diana
and the press to shape but both Charles
and the palace know that he can't remain
a mere bystander to his own story his
future succession to the throne May well
depend on restoring his reputation with
Camilla not Diana by his side he turns
to a friend and broadcaster Jonathan
dimbleby
together they develop a documentary to
Mark Charles's 25th year as Prince of
Wales a documentary in which they will
also address for the first time
allegations about Charles's relationship
with Camilla Parker Bowles it began like
a Hollywood epic child's decision to be
tracked by a camera for a year was a
gamble on the 29th of June 1994 Charles
the private man the public role was
broadcast on ITV
an opportunity to perhaps clear the air
in front of an audience of 14 million
people about his relationship with
Camilla a chance to set the record
straight
he first begins to suggest that
speculation about an affair with Camilla
is just that speculation Mrs Barker
bills is
a great friend of mine I have
a large number of friends I'm terribly
lucky to have she has been a friend for
a very long time and
along with a lot of other friends and
will continue to be a friend for a very
long time
but then he was asked about the collapse
of his marriage had he been faithful to
Diana
yes
until it became
irretrievably broken down
as both having tried
what exactly did that mean had he been
faithful or not
what was meant to be a PR Victory turned
into a PR disaster for the already
floundering Prince and the following
morning Jonathan dimly himself is
interviewed on Sky News the prince I'm
quite certain was under the impression
that I was asking him about his
unfaithfulness with Camilla Parker
Bowles and that's what he was answering
but I tried to make that marriage work
only when he was dead irretrievably
broken did I then take comfort with my
very close friend
question anymore
no question whatsoever within hours the
prince of wales's private secretary
calls a bombshell press briefing the
first time Charles admits that he did
have an affair with Camilla it made
Diana seem unassailable proved
everything that she'd been saying was
true
weeks later in July 1994 Camilla loses
her mother Rosalind Shand
grief stricken she flees to Portugal
leaving her husband behind
his wife's absence gives Andrew Parker
Bowles the time to reflect on the state
of their marriage and he decides he can
no longer see a life with Camilla Andrew
and Camilla Parker Bowles have been
living apart for two years enjoying an
apparent open marriage but it's thought
the situation became increasingly
difficult after Prince Charles's
television interview with Jonathan
dimbleby Camilla's husband Andrew has
been the butt of media jives ever since
former silver stick in waiting to the
queen so dutiful he laid down his wife
for his country now the marriage between
Camilla and her husband is soon to be
over
the couple after 21 years of marriage
decide to divorce things just couldn't
get any worse
or could they
they do
in 1995 Princess Diana then still very
much the darling of the British public
agrees to a No Holds Barred interview
with the journalist Martin beshear for a
prime time edition of BBC Panorama Phil
Craig again
I think by the time Donna sits down with
Martin beshear she's separated there's
no divorce she's still having a pretty
successful public life the interview
remains mired in controversy years later
it was found that Martin Bashir had used
fake personal documents to help secure
the interview
it was an entirely desperate story about
Martin beshear and what he was telling
Diana that she was being spied on
her phone was being tapped that people
close to her being paid and that fed a
paranoia which I think at the beginning
one could understand in Diana but I
think by the end it had genuinely become
a problem however none of this was known
at the time and 23 million people tuned
in to watch we were all on the edge of
our seats would she settle all scores
with her Nemesis Camilla we weren't
disappointed when Diana delivered a
quote which she had obviously rehearsed
and many of the British public can
recite word for word
there were three of us in this marriage
so it was a bit crowded
like her husband she used the interview
to clear the air
Diner is again headline news around the
world
and like her husband she admitted
adultery in her case with former Cavalry
Officer James Hewitt Diana said she
didn't want a divorce that her husband
hadn't discussed it but she said she had
no doubt who was to blame
the Princess of Wales said she didn't
think she would be Queen and wasn't sure
that the prince would be king but she
denied claims that she was out to
destroy the monarchy
the scale of the crisis is now gripping
the palace ever tighter even catching
out our own Simon McCoy
things were far worse than anybody had
been reporting up until then and it laid
out very very clearly just how
desperately unhappy those two were and
how bad things had got the Diana effect
was massive there was huge sympathy for
her you know she was
the most popular person in this country
married to the least popular person and
there is something unedifying about
people washing their dirty Linen in
public in the way that they did
but I think both of them felt there was
nothing left to do
[Music]
someone did know what to do
the queen I think the queen realized
that the breakup of the marriage of her
eldest son of the second in line to the
throne
caused massive problems for the monarchy
and and as such as Monarch she was the
one who said to Charles look that you
need to you need to get this divorce
through she was desperately worried
about what was going on if there was
blame to be pointed to anyone it was
Charleston of course that Camilla Prince
Charles listens attentively and agrees
to the divorce ordered by his mother
green eyes I was granted and the divorce
finalized on the 28th of August
1996. Diana will move on but lose the
protective shield of the officers who
kept the paparazzi at Bay for Charles he
still enjoys the protection of the firm
the royal family and his mother but at a
cost will that cost be to lose the love
of his life Camilla forever
Charles assures his mother that when the
time comes he will do his duty as King
Alone crisis averted but almost exactly
a year later on the 31st of August 1997
tragic turn
that nobody could ever have expected
we're just receiving the the sad news
here at Sky Center confirmation from our
very own foreign secretary Robin Cook
who's in the Far East at the moment that
Diana Princess of Wales has in fact been
killed in that car accident in Paris uh
just a few hours ago
our head of news called me in the early
hours of that Sunday morning Dodie had
died Diana was in a motor car with her
companion of recent days Dodie fired
Diana injured but stable could I make my
way into the studio I grabbed a jacket
and dashed out of the door Into the
Night
in Paris the princess was being taken
from the wreckage and rushed to a
hospital in the southeast of the capital
first medical reports indicated that she
was suffering from concussion a broken
arm and cuts to her thighs it later
emerged that the princess had suffered
massive chest injuries
there had been extreme concern that
Diana was very seriously injured when
she was taken from the wreckage there
was a and used blackout to all intents
and purposes for a significant amount of
time
um confirmation from the interior
Minister from Paris for a short time and
now there is confirmation that Diana
Princess of Wales has died she died at
4am after going into cardiac arrest that
according to doctors at the hospital in
Paris Diana Princess of Wales is dead
Balmoral Castle and a shocked Charles
called Camilla as soon as he heard that
Diana had died
he didn't know how to tell his sons
princess William knife 15 and 12 year
old Harry
that they'd lost their mother
Simon McCoy
when Diana died
it was Rock Bottom for both of them and
I think you could see it on Charles's
face
anybody who says he wasn't affected by
Diana's death needs to look at the
pictures
and look at what he did he went straight
to Paris he brought the body of his
ex-wife home you know he he was
as dutiful as it was possible to be at
the time and I don't think that any
criticism could be leveled to him for it
but at the time the public blamed him
for Diana's death blamed him for the
entire mess
and he and he shouldered that
how did this tragedy look for him would
he be blamed
would Camilla
Next Time on Queen Camilla For the Love
of Charles
operation Putting on the Ritz Camilla
the fightback begins
here we go I think
here we go this has been worked out to
the nth degree and very carefully worked
out on the back of public reaction
but not only the public before they
marry the queen too there was some
concern in the early days that the queen
had not been fully supportive of the
marriage
you can listen to all episodes now Queen
Camilla For the Love of Charles is a Sky
News podcast production presented by me
K Burley the producer is soila aparicio
assistant producers are Alex Eden and
Lily Thomas sound design is by James
Bradshaw Rob mulhern is the exec
producer and Paul stanworth the editor